from tomorrow in holland none of this
will be allowed all non-essential shops
will shut along with bars and
restaurants as the country goes back
into lockdown schools and universities
will also close until mid-january a move
the dutch prime minister called
unavoidable netherlands
the netherlands is again shutting down
that is unavoidable because of the fifth
wave that is coming at us with the
omicron variant
omicron is spreading even faster than we
feared and so we must act now to prevent
as much of the worst as possible the
country recorded nearly 15 000 new
coveted infections in the last 24 hours
and many here had already feared the
worst hitting the shops ahead of the
announcement to make the most of their
freedom whilst they still could
that the lockdown
i find it pretty intense that there is
another lockdown coming up i'm dependent
on my income from this store and i do
have a website but that represents 10 or
maybe 20 of my turnover or the other 80
is coming from the physical store so yes
i am going to feel this very strongly
across europe tighter restrictions have
prompted a wave of unrest in dusseldorf
in germany thousands demonstrated
against compulsory vaccinations for
certain professions
in turin in italy it was the prospect of
covid passports
[Applause]
an issue that also saw protests in paris
back in holland no demonstrations but
doubt over whether all the rules will be
followed particularly on indoor mixing
for the coming week
people may invite only two persons per
day in their house that's that's a lot
for christmas uh it will be four first
persons but still many families are are
bigger so um i hear a lot of people
around me that say we are gonna
celebrate christmas maybe with six or
eight people so it's not
like every uh dutchman will follow all
the rules i don't think that will be the
case
the rules may be familiar but another
coved christmas is far from festive iva
bennett sky news